Clutter.
This is when you have too many lights bunched up together...
...or when the lights are grouped in very confusing ways.
It can make you confused or dizzy looking at them.
Light trespass.
It is the light falling where it is not intended or needed.
How bad you feel when your neighbor's security lights shining through your bedroom windows...
...and lighting up your room all night?
Sources of light pollution include building exterior and interior lighting,...
...advertising, commercial properties, factories, offices,...
...street lights and illuminated sporting venues.
We need light at night,...
...but the fact is that too much outdoor lighting used at night...
...is inefficient and completely unnecessary.
This light and the electricity used to create it is being wasted by spilling it into the sky...
...rather than focusing it onto the actual objects in areas that people want illuminated.
This kind of LED droplight could reduce unnecessary light pollution in building interiors.
We should ensure that light is only directed below the horizontal.
Which means less light is wasted through directing it outwards and upwards.
Light pollution affects every citizen, increasing energy consumption,...
...disrupting the ecosystem and wildlife,...
...harming human health and also affecting crime and safety.
So we should try to reduce this.
Bye-bye!